good evening members and
members of public and offices
welcome to the cabinet meeting
just some
housekeeping
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated please vacate the offices
by the stairs please do not use the
lifts
assemble in hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber please switch off or turn to
silent your mobile phones and do not
make or receive calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
i don't believe there's anybody in the
public gallery but i will ask if anyone
intends to film the meeting
the following members have asked to
speak under council
procedure rules 20.1
item five councillor whitehead item six
councillor everett councillor yates does
anybody else wish to speak under rule
20.1
councillor austin what item
item six
there are no apologies for absence from
the cabinet
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
minutes of the previous meeting to
approve the summary of recommendations
and decisions of the cabinet meeting
held on the 16th of december 2021
copiers attached the agenda pack
i propose we approve the minutes do i
have a seconder
councillor david saunders
do members agree
item 4 council tax base to introduce
councillor david saunders
thank you leader
gender item for as you quite rightly say
council tax base which is covered
on pages 9 to 17 in your agenda pack
this report presents for approval to
council the council tax base for
2022-23 which has been increased by 1.86
on the previous financial year the
report also recommends maintaining the
existing schemes for local council tax
support and premiums on long-term empty
properties
i move the recommendations as detailed
one to four on page nine thank you
thank you councillor saunders has moved
does it do i have a second uh
councillors pugh
there are no speakers under 20.1
so do members agree
breathe
[Applause]
item 5
hra budget
to introduce councillor david saunders
thank you again
general item 5 hra budget 2022-23
is covered on pages 19-34
within your agenda pack
next year's hra budget is underpinned by
a 4.1 percent increase in rents next
year the majority of which will be
covered by increased benefit or
universal credit payments to our tenants
this increase
this rent increase is needed to continue
to drive the hra to a balanced and
sustainable financial position and also
to finance our ambassador ambitious
house building program and housing
investment plan
i move the recommendations one to five
on page 19.
thank you councillor saunders and do i
have a second down
counsellor
bob bayford
speaking under rule 20.1 councillor
whitehead
thank you very much leader um my point
is in relation to 0.3.9
and the obvious need for our housing
stock to meet net zero carbon
um as we've identified 12 million pounds
towards the essential capital project
over the next 30 years but we still have
26 million pounds to find do we know the
likelihood of meeting this through the
social housing decarbonisation fund or
do we have an estimation of likely
required borrowing
thank
you
council saunders if you'd like to
respond i'd love to respond
thank you councillor whitehead this is
not my portfolio
i'm interested in the financial side of
the activities so if i may i will defer
to the director of housing and planning
who i hope can put some
light on the situation
thank you council whitehead for the
question um
so we have done some um work on
projecting the potential costs
in the housing revenue account um for
meeting the climate change objectives of
net zero for the housing stock
and you're quite right in the question
that the cost of that um exceeds the
available resources that we currently
have identified in the plan for things
like energy efficiency and heating
upgrades
and
that
that that gap will need to be covered
from um external sources in some way um
the social housing i don't have the
exact figures in front of me i'm afraid
but the social housing decarbonisation
fund so national program funded by
government does have a substantial
amount of money in available for exactly
that purpose
and as we
move forward with this work uh we will
be seeking support from that fund to
help with the costs of meeting those
objectives
at this stage i'm afraid we don't have
the exact figures
but you're absolutely right there is
likely to be a substantial requirement
for external funding
thank you very much for the answer
thank thank you are you okay with that
counsellor saunders um i think we're
moving on to um item six budget 20 22 23
and mid-term financial strategy oh sorry
we haven't actually voted on there on
them
you have to just wait and put my hand up
sorry yes two members agree great
sorry item six budget 2022-23 a
medium-term financial strategy
22-26 to introduce councillor saunders
thank you very much before i introduce
the item once again i'd like to place on
record the help and assistance that has
been given by
chris blundell and his financial team
particularly with regards to the budget
briefings which every member of this
council has had the opportunity of
attending and asking relevant questions
on the evening thank you
general item 6 budget 2022-23
and mtfs
2022-23 covered by pages 35 to 78 in
your agenda pack
i'm very pleased to be able to present a
balanced budget for the 2022-23
to cabinet tonight
just a few months back we were
forecasting a significant budget gap but
with a planned and cautious approach
combined with an efficient savings plan
we have been able to balance our budget
despite what may seem like a lengthy and
complicated process this level of
planning is of critical importance it's
how we continue to deliver the services
that matter to the people and protect
and support our most vulnerable
residents
[Applause]
planning our finances in this way means
we are on the right track for balancing
our budget in the coming years
our balanced budget position has been
supported in part by the very welcome
additional funding that has been
provided by to us by the government the
next year however much of this funding
is temporary and therefore this cabinet
proposes to use these monies in a
financially sound way
for example we plan to use the extra
one-off new homes bonus windfall to pay
off debt and hence putting us on a solid
financial footing as we prepare for the
reform of local government funding and
the uncertainty this brings
despite the additional funding we have
received it has been necessary to find
budget savings in order to balance next
year's budget one of our priorities
throughout the budget setting process
has been to protect jobs as much as
possible and as such a key component of
our budget strategy has been to look for
savings from vacant posts
i am therefore pleased to present
savings
a quarter of a million pounds has been
found from this review
in addition to this we have also found
almost another four hundred thousand
pounds from further savings efficiencies
and income generation opportunities
finally the proposed increase in council
tax at five pounds per band d
equivalent plot property
represents an increase of less than 10
pence a week for each household
i move the recommendations one and two
as detailed on page 35. thank you
thank you councillor saunders council
saunders has moved
would have a second councillor george
cup
speaking under 20.1 i have first
councillor everett
yeah thank you leader and um i'd like to
echo what council saunders has said in
terms of
praising mr blundell and the finance
team for their hard work and
particularly for the briefing that mr
blundell gave to the labor group that
was very helpful and appropriate and
labor group will continue to engage in
the budget process as you'd expect
obviously we welcome the unexpected
additional funding
although i would say that it does point
to the uncertain environment that we
operate in and the difficulty of
actually managing our budget since we
only find out at the last minute how
much money we're going to get
um this is not a new thing as we all
know
um in respect of the new homes bonus
money um while it's particularly welcome
it's not government large yes
it's been triggered
um by the council exceeding the
threshold
of new properties and properties brought
back into use i mean i'm particularly
proud of the number of empty homes
brought back into use by this council i
think it's something that we perform
particularly well at although perhaps we
have more of them in the first place
um somebody would be able to give me
some statistical advice on that i'm sure
i mean the new homes bonus story reminds
me that um this is more or less where i
came in eight years ago when new homes
bonus had just been launched and we were
all exploring what was what it was for
and discussing whether or not it ought
to be built into the base budget
um clearly that's not the case and
unfortunately
um
practically all of this new funding if
not all of it is uh one-off payments so
it's not quite party time in fanec yet
even if it is in downing street
um so this extra money can't be used
unfortunately for doing the things that
our residents would most like which is
to improve
street cleansing and rubbish collection
i appreciate the council has other ideas
about those but there is a limit to the
way we can do it because we can't build
it into the base budget or guarantee
what might be the situation next year
and it seems to me that this uncertainty
which doesn't just extend to annual
funding extensive the whole funding
formula is the biggest challenge that
the council currently faces
and i don't think whoever was in power
will be able to come up with a perfect
solution to that at this time
i'm sure that
through the cycle of meetings over the
next month we will have more to say
about the budget but that's all i wish
to say tonight
thank you councillor everett um would
you like to respond although there
wasn't necessarily a question
much of
what councillor everett said
particularly one-off payments and the
uncertainty i absolutely agree with
and i look forward to further debate
with regards to the budget before we
reach the month of february thank you
next to speak under 20.1 councillor
yates
thank you leader
the labour group have gone through the
budget in detail
and we do believe there's real
opportunity for investment in our public
assets
investment into our housing program and
an opportunity to support officers in
tackling the climate emergency
as mentioned already we'll go through
the details these changes at the
appropriate time
which for us is the review and scrutiny
meeting but we're keen to stress we want
cross-party support for these measures
and believe they do make financial sense
will result in a balanced budget
and do represent the expectations of the
people who've done it thank you
thank you councillor yates you just wish
to respond
i'd like to thank councillor yates and
look forward further debate
as always
speaking under 20.1 councillor
austin thank you leader i'd like to
echo what's been said about the um
success of chris rondell and the finance
team in getting us to this point and the
helpfulness of the budget briefing which
for me as a relatively new council was
particularly useful thank you very much
i just wanted to ask one question which
actually picks up on what various other
speakers have said which was about the
vehicle replacement policy and whether
we're going to take the opportunity in
the light of the climate emergency to
trial
for example an electric waste vehicle
and whether we are considering the
possibility when we're looking at new uh
waste rounds
of
possibly
investing in
at least one smaller vehicle that could
offer recycling services to some of
those streets that don't have curbside
recycling at the moment because the
streets are too narrow for the existing
vehicles to get down i'd be really
interested in whether there are any
possibilities there to extend our work
on on addressing climate change thank
you
thank you council austin i that counts
as soon as you'd probably like to come
back but also i think councillor baifen
can also add to
to commentary on this one yes i welcome
commentary from council bayford uh what
i can say is that cabinet have
considered
electric vehicles electric phrases um
there we don't at the moment have the
infrastructure
to seriously consider it in the in the
short term it's a long-term objective at
the moment i am advised that the
electric freighters although
you'll see buses and coaches which are
working quite well in taxes
the issue with the elect with the having
electric freighters if that is the
lifting gear on the rear
absorbs the battery power very very
rapidly and we probably have to invest
in more freighters than we currently
have in order the phrases can come back
to the depot if we had the
infrastructure at the depot to charge
them in order to get recharged but it is
something that we've been looking at
seriously and considering um but uh for
the purposes of this budget um i'm
afraid it's it's something that um it's
on our wish list but we can't actually
fulfill that wish within the next
financial year thank you council
bathroom yeah i mean i think
council someone has actually said a lot
of what i would say um but there you go
no i mean it's something that we're very
conscious of something that we'd love to
do but you're probably aware at the
moment that electric freight is about
twice the cost the ordinary ones so you
know that puts us in a very very
difficult position
um
of course what we're hoping for is that
they're going to be
one improvements in the efficiency of
creating those vehicles and bringing the
costs down there's also going to be
issues about hydrogen powered vehicles
and that's something we're looking at
um but we are very very conscious that
that's where we've got to get to in the
end and as soon as we can we will
great thank you both
so this has been moved and seconded do
cabinet agree
agree thank you
so
item seven of the councillor saunders
show is for the treasury management
strategy and annual investment strategy
to introduce councillor saunders
thank you very much
treasury management and annual
investment strategy 2020 to 23
covered by pages 79 to 124 believe it or
not
this report is required in accordance
with the cip fa code of practice on
treasury management it covers our
capital spending and financial plans and
its treasury strategy backed by
prudential
indicators and limits
the report also presents for approval
the council's minimum revenue provision
policy capital strategy and investment
strategy and non-treasury investments
report for the next financial year
this report was considered by the
governance and audit committee on the
first of december 2021
and therefore move the cabinet approves
the recommendations a to f on page 80.
thank you
thank you councillor saunders do i have
a second off
councillor jill bateford
um i don't know why but no one's asked
to speak under 20.1 because this is a
very interesting subject but um
useful to say but other than the fact
that obviously um we might be slightly
better off with the raising of interest
rates that have come about recently um
not sure how how high they'll go but uh
um no doubt any anything that will be
gratefully received within the treasury
fund
so
councillors agree
so
that concludes the business for this
evening and
[Music]
have a good evening everybody and thank
you for attending thank you charles